[Musique]
ces images publiées sur les réseaux
sociaux montre la voiture de daria
douguine en flammes
selon les premières informations une
bombe aurait été placée dans le v u est
ce que conduisait la jeune femme sa mort
a été constatée sur place mais c'est
plutôt son père alexandre douguine un
proche du président russe vladimir
poutine qui aurait été visé par cette
attaque le jeune philosophe et ultra
nationaliste c'est nardant défenseur du
monde rue une idéologie qui met l'accent
sur la restauration du pouvoir de la
russie suivant surnommé le cerveau de
poutine il rit plus enflé l'évasion
russe en ukraine lui milite depuis des
années pour que l'ukraine soit détruite
pour que les craintes soient bombardées
que le crâne revienne dans le giron de
la russie et sa fille a un peu pris le
relais de tout cela et ces derniers mois
elle a été très présente dans les
talk-shows les émissions de télévision
aux russes dans lesquels des fonds des
mêmes théories
le père et la fille venait de participer
à un festival culturel et devait rentrer
ensemble au dernier moment alexandre
douguine aurait toutefois décidé de
prendre la route seule une enquête pour
homicide est en cours afin de faire la
lumière sur cet attentat en période de
guerre l'ukraine ni toutefois toute
implication dans l'explosion
et d'ailleurs sur le terrain cette
guerre dure depuis bientôt six mois qui
est créé davantage de bombardements dans
les jours à venir à l'heure où l'ukraine
fêtera le jour de son indépendance le 24
août prochain
au sud l'inquiétude plane autour de la
centrale nucléaire de zappos budget à la
plus grande d'europe toujours occupée
par l'armée russe la recrudescence des
combats autour de cette centrale s'est
re surgir le sec d'une catastrophe pire
que celle de tchernobyl
dirigeants américains français allemands
et britanniques ont d'ailleurs appelé à
la retenue dimanche ici daniel kadjo
radio canada montréal